outlast was a huge success for indie  horror games so sequel was all but  inevitable but we won't be getting it  this year I'm Tony and this is your  terrifying gamespot news update  originally slated for release at the end  of 2016 out last two has been pushed to  early 2017 developer red barrels  explained the delay in a Facebook post  saying it needs the extra time for  polish it said quote we're taking a  little more time to make sure our vision  for out last two is in no way  compromised and is the experience you  deserve if a little more testing means a  better game overall I can't complain out  last two releases on ps4 xbox one and pc  in the first quarter of 2017 we've  gotten some hands-on time with the game  so you can head over to gamespot to  check out our impression and for all the  latest from the realm of videogame  horror you're already in the right place